all right uh we're on lift number three
the back squat so these are the
progressions for learning it um he's
going to Center himself on the bar very
much like the shoulder
press and then he is is that tall enough
for you it'll work what okay it'll work
all right he's going to go under the
bar and lay this on what we call the
scapula sh shelf okay so he has his
scapula and then right on top though
there's a kind of Ridge there and that
is where the bar is uh going to rest so
don't rest it higher than that and not
lower than that so higher than that go
ahead and demonstrate he's going to put
it up on your neck and stuff we don't
want it there okay you go too low and
it'll slide down your back which we
don't want that to happen either so
right on that scapula shelf and then to
help lock it in place uh you're going to
lift your elbows up and that kind of
puts pressure on it and it stops it from
sliding down depending on your
flexibility you can do different things
with your hands so you can uh kind of
grab the bar if you want some people can
some people can't and they're kind of
holding it in place you can also put
your uh wrist over it uh or anything in
between so this is how Taylor likes to
keep that bar in place with that
friction there but key is that the
elbows are more up okay uh once he's in
position he will straighten his knees so
he's using his uh whole body to get it
off he'll take one to two steps back and
the goal here is not to walk for forever
with that bar cuz eventually it's going
to be heavy and we don't want to walk
with it we're moving away from the
upright just to clear uh the chin up
bars or whatever else is with your squat
rack okay his feet are going to be be uh
a little wider than his shoulder width
and we would like to see the feet
straight okay so you use that mid toe
alignment again uh but your flexibility
might require you to do something
different so I'm going to I know Taylor
can do it so I'm going to have him
straighten his right foot out in a
little more okay and then what you're
doing here is the bar's weight is going
to be Center entered over that midfoot
okay over that midfoot and so you have
to find your knee angle pelvic angle and
torso tilt to get it there but we want
your torso to be tilted more or less
nearer the 45 so uh kind of a
conventional wisdom here is that you
imagine lasers are coming out of your
nipples and they'll be hit in the ground
at a 45° angle keep your nose and neck
uh neutral to that line so you don't
want to look up can you show you don't
want to do that okay you keep your nose
on that same 45° angle and then what you
want to do is bring your hips back
towards the rear as opposed to your
knees forward lowering the bar up and
down on the midfoot line and you want to
go all the way down until the bottom of
your legs are parallel to the ground at
the knee and then you come back up
without undoing your torso can and you
go back down and you would do that for a
set of five we don't want to bounce at
the end and we don't want to go past
that parallel knee angle at the
bottom and we'll say this is five at
which point just like the shoulder press
he can straighten up a little bit here
to walk in he walks in he hits the
upright with the bar bends his knees and
lowers it on the J Hooks and then he
comes
out okay out of number three and number
four lift so out of the the back squats
and the dead lifts the back squat is
generally a safer lift um and so we tend
to use it more than the dead lifts
however the dead lifts I find uh get a
little more lat strength going um so
sometimes I like to do that but you have
to be very very uh very very careful
with these lifts because you're going to
put a lot of weight on them and the rule
here is that you only lift to the form
form so we're not weightlifters we're
not keeping track of personal records or
anything like that and if we can't lift
to the form as you just saw demonstrated
we have too much weight on and weight
comes off what you've noticed is that
only the bench press is the only lift
where we use a spotter for uh on all the
other lifts if you can't lift the bar
meaning you can't maintain form you got
to rect the bar take weight off that's
our rules all right we'll put some
weight on it and we'll watch this under
resistance all right so now with some
weight he'll do a a five a a set of five
reps so he's going to Center himself
he's go underneath use his legs to come
up elbows up bar on the scapula shelf he
walks out one to two steps gets his
forward can 45° angle and then he does
his five
walks back in hits the uprights bends
his KNE and bar goes on the J Hooks
comes out all right uh on the bench
press should you have a catastrophic
failure you have your spotter there to
help keep that bar off of you on the
shoulder press if you have a
catastrophic failure you would just drop
the bar in front of you it's easy to do
uh if you could not put it back on on
the J Hooks on the squat you're under
the bar and so you have to have a way of
ditching the bar and here we use a kind
of Rustler's move so he's going to uh
shrug himself forward and under the bar
and Let It Drop behind him if he has a
catastrophic failure he will not try to
lower it slowly cuz he can't get out
from under it so you just ditch the bar
and it looks something like this it
looks exactly like this okay so he's
doing everything we just did and then
he's in his form and he
realizes crap he's going to ditch
it and you just let it fall behind you
okay never get yourself under the bar
when you're ditching it and for this
reason we have those secondary uprights
behind they trap the bar in there uh
this is a squat rack that James made if
you'd like this I'm sure he could make
it for you too um and then some of the
ones you buy in the store that say
they're squat rcks they don't come with
that and so for that reason your partner
whoever you're lifting with you have to
make sure they're not behind you and
they're ready for you if you have to
ditch that bar so it doesn't hurt them
or hit them in any way